the president reportedly told his top
White House lawyer to stop Attorney
General Jeff Sessions from withdrawing
from the Russia investigation the New
York Times and Associated Press say the
White House Counsel spoke two sessions
but failed to change his mind
Special Counsel Robert Muller is
investigating whether that and other
actions could be obstruction of justice
Jeff Piquet's is tracking the Muller
probe Jeff good morning good morning
overnight the Department of Justice
responded to the New York Times report
which also alleged that Attorney General
Jeff Sessions sent an aide to Capitol
Hill to dig up dirt on been FBI director
James Comey four days before FBI
director James Comey was abruptly fired
by the president last May according to
the New York Times one of mr. sessions
as aides asked a congressional staff
member whether he had damaging
information about mr. Comey which was
part of an apparent effort to undermine
the FBI director a DOJ spokeswoman told
CBS News this did not happen and would
not happen plain and simple
The Times also writes that when the
White House Counsel failed to stop
sessions from recusing himself the
president erupted in anger saying he
needed his attorney general to protect
him the newly released book fire and
fury also includes a meeting aboard Air
Force One in July that could represent
obstruction of justice
according to author Michael wolf the
president hope Hicks Jared Kushner and
Ivanka Trump huddled over how to respond
to reports about the Trump Tower meeting
involving Donald Trump jr. and Russian
operatives in 2016 the decision say the
meeting was primarily about Russian
adoptions by Americans which was false
Trump jr. later acknowledged the meeting
was convened because he was told the
Russians had negative information about
Hillary Clinton Scott Fredrickson is a
former federal prosecutor do you think
the president is in grave legal jeopardy
I don't think I would put it at that
level of warning where would you put it
he is in a most serious situation with a
special counsel looking right at him
according to the New York Times
president Trump described the Russia
investigation as fabricated and
politically motivated in a letter to
then FBI director Comey but White House
aides stopped him from sending that
letter Norah incredible reporting Jeff
thank you so much